les médecins ont joué un rôle central
dans les crimes des nazis voici ce que
révèle un rapport de la revue
scientifique britannique The L 7 qui
rappelle que les crimes n'ont pas été
commis uniquement par des médecins
extrémistes ou sous la contrainte par
exemple en 1942 max Clara un anatomiste
nazi avait administré de la vitamine C à
des prisonniers condamnés à mort pour
ensuite étudier sa répartition dans leur
tissu après la mort traitant ainsi le
prisonnier comme s'il était déjà un
cadavre mais l'exemple le plus connu
demeure sans doute les nombreuses études
portant sur les effets de la fin extrême
dans le getto de Varsovie élaboré par le
professeur et officiers SS Johann Paul
Kemer et qui a constitué la première
recherche approfondie de ce sujet dans
la littérature médicale selon le rapport
en 1945 entre 50 et 65 % des médecins
allemands non juifs avaient ainsi
rejoint le parti nazi une proportion
bien plus élevée que dans toute autre
profession universitaire l'influence de
la recherche nazie a parfois été
fondamentale comme sur les effets du
tabac et de l'alcool sur le corps qui a
été alimenté par des recherches menées à
l'époque nazie au point que certains
criminels ont acquis une renommée
durable sans jamais révéler le contexte
de leur recherch comme l'une des
fondatrices de de la pédopsychiatrie
ellizabeth Ecker qui a reçu l'Ordre du
Mérite en 1979 par l'Allemagne alors
qu'elle avait envoyé de nombreux mineurs
à la mort ce rapport décrit comme le
plus complet réalisé sur les atrocités
commises recommande donc aux médecins
d'apprendre à s'opposer à des directives
qui posent des dilemmes éthiques citant
notamment les soignants qui encadrent
les interrogatoires de terroristes ceux
qui pratiquent le triage dans les
hôpitaux lors d'afflux massifs de
passion ou encore ceux qui encadrent la
fin de vie la revue recommande également
que les faits historiques soient
intégrés à leur for
pour rappel au total les programmes
eugénistes d'euthanasie et les
expériences humaines brutales dans un
cadre médical ont fait au moins 230000
morts parmi les handicapés les juifs et
les déportés dont 7000 à 10000 enfants
et plus de 300000 stérilisations forcées
[Musique]
pratiqué